[Music]
in this video I'll bring you the leaked
outline for episode 3 of the final
season this entire episode is devoted to
the battle between the living and dead
the battle for Winterfell this battle
has already been confirmed by a bunch of
leaked photos so even if the South line
is not real this battle is still
happening however why I think this
outline might be the actual line is due
to a fact that it's been sent to me in
August last year while gamo trans turn
filming its final season in October as
months before the filming started and
therefore months before any leaked
photos could be taken and yet totally
photos and leaves that follow match
perfectly with this outline the Sultan
might potentially contain some major
spoilers if it turns out to be an actual
outline so if you don't want anything
spoiled it's time for you to close this
video animes this outline sees huge
battle for Winterfell with quite a few
main characters dying with some almost
dying and with a few major twists as
well as with Jon Snow being captured and
Yara creature being rescued so let's
just jump into it the episode starts
with Cersei giving birth to a black
haired son we see the nat king flying
vissarion we see John and Danny on a
ship we see Winterfell burning with CG
injury and Arya travelling the king's
road and we see on Greyjoy with the
Lannister army in the golden companies
sailing north brain is having visions of
past and future events this is an
interesting start of episode 3
it starts with Cersei giving birth to a
black haired son now we know that sir
she had miscarriage in season 8 premiere
so she is not giving birth to a child in
the current timeline the outline also
says that this is basically happening in
rands vision either in past or future
since it's highly unlikely that Cersei
will get pregnant again automation give
a birth or a child I think it's safe to
say that this vision of a child birth is
something that's happened in the past
early on in Game of Thrones you've paid
close attention you'd notice two scenes
in which Cersei talks about her black
haired son that supposedly died shortly
after the birth I lost my first boy he
was a fighter too Cersei talks with
Catelyn Stark about it and later with
the fighter himself Robert Baratheon is
the black-haired son of Sir Sam Roberts
surely dead or is he perhaps alive
someone we know I have already made a
full video regarding a theory image
ginjuries this black haired son so
before you continue watching this video
you might want to see all the clues and
hints proving this theory right because
who knows maybe Ganges Cho lineage will
be revealed to him later in this episode
anyways back to the outline it says that
we see a shot of the army of the
marching towards Winterfell they're very
close John snow the nearest cent sorry a
double styrian miss sandy great warm con
Aubrey and Podrick Thurmond Ellis car
certainly in a moment Lord glower Lord
mannerly Lord sermon Jorah centered gain
varies Dorset Lord Royce Sam Robb in the
rain and bran Stark are having a meeting
in the main hall Brent tells them that
the entire army of the Dead is marching
towards them all except the night King
Brent says that he saw the night King
flying visitor in South then he says she
will ride dragon and take raiga with her
to stop the night king some agree some
don't with this decision but the nurse
insists that her word is final
since estates that her doubt regarding
sources promised help seems to be prune
right there replies they cannot say for
certain just yet he insists that the
weather conditions might be the reason
it takes them too long to arrive Brennan
to wrap their conversation says that his
sister's his Army's sailing north to aid
them in the world to come
Turan proposes to defend Winterfell from
the army of the Dead from its walls
which he says is the only advantage
general refuses his proposal and says he
has a better idea the last episode
ending with a horn being blown now the
arm of the Dare is even closer in the
plain sight I'd say and the living are
having the last-minute preparations
regarding their defenses Brent says he's
seen the night came flying south which
would be a vision his head in the
beginning of this episode then he's
apparently leaving her armies at
Winterfell to defend it against the
incoming horde while she's taking her
dragons to find and confront the night
King and his Sunday dragon before he
forms a new army in the south bran also
shares his vision about urine and the
golden company is selling towards north
which he says are coming to their aid
could he be wrong are they really coming
to the raid the Alton continues with a
third meeting John and Sam speak about
brains abilities
John wonders why don't Brown just see
everything that's happened and is
happening and informed them about
everything important sen tells him that
it's not how it works
he says bran cannot be everywhere or see
everything at the same time he said that
bran can't see everything that's
happened or is happening but he can see
it piece by piece he needs someone to
guide him and tell him where to go and
what to see this is something that has
huge amount of fans confused with bran
being the three-eyed Raven people think
that he knows everything that's happened
or is happening which simply is not true
to explain it better let's take a look
on how the actor who plays bran stark
explained how exactly his powers work on
Game of Thrones the way brains power
works at the moment is that his
basically got a Kindle library of the
whole history of the universe he says he
just hasn't read every book yet and the
all three eyed Raven
has set in that tree for a thousand
years and read through every piece of
history and has accessed at all he
continues with but for now he needs
people to tell him what they want him to
see that's exactly how brain so John's
parents being married in secret ceremony
someone told him to check out if his
happen he accessed it and confirmed it
he doesn't know everything but he can go
and check it out and I'm glad that the
show will explain in the next season
because it has many people confused
basically what happens in this case is
that branch saw her on sailing with
services armies north and by hearing the
sir she promised to send help he assumes
that they're coming to the north side
however no one told Brent to go back and
check out services plans that she
discussed with urine and the leader of
the golden company and to check if
they're really coming to the north side
the outline continues with me sandy s
Danny if she's told John about her
pregnancy
Danny orders sandy and mr. Walton to
stay quiet about her pregnancy she says
if John finds it out he won't let her
ride joggin and if she doesn't lead her
dragazine to barrels the words lost
sometimes later Danny flies urging him
south
looking for the night king in his Sunday
dragon let me stop right there to say
that this is not coming as a huge
surprise there's been many scenes
throughout the previous season for
sharing Dennis pregnancy with Jon Snow
and occurred to you she might not have
been a reliable source of information
let's hope then he's not riding in
tonight king strap the ought London
states that the next scene shows us the
full strength of John and Dana's armies
at Winterfell the northerners have
jealous weapons the isalud carrier
dragon glass-tipped spears
archers have Jagan glass arrowheads we
don't see though the track in nor the
Knights of the Vale this part has been
both expected and confirmed by the
league for us John went to Dragonstone
to meet Danny not only to meet the
Dragon Queen but also to mind Jerry
unless that is located over there with
John and then his rival at Winterfell of
course that they brought journalist from
Jay Johnstone to use it in the war to
come and therefore their army scaring
the journalists made weapons doesn't
come as a surprise there are so few
leaked photos in which we can see the
unsullied carrying a journalist
experimental for Winterfell confirming
this outline Sakura see the outline
continues where the gates open Justin
leads most of the armies outside the
walls of interval we see Jon Snow
leading the northerners the unsullied in
a little force of the Nights Watch they
are solid form a large unit phalanx
formations John Stumpf the northerner
sent a man of the Nights Watch take a
defensive position behind Lions of Tsavo
DeFries with dragonglass taking
of the spikes let me stop right here to
say that the same goes for this part of
the outline as well some parts are not
coming as a huge surprise well some have
kind of been confirmed by the leaked
photos I'm not gonna lie at first it
doesn't make any sense to leave
Winterfell and face the threat outside
its walls which stood as their only
advantage however then you also need to
rethink it and keeping in mind that
Winterfell is not big enough to have all
their armies inside it there and
proposed to defend Winterfell from the
inside from its walls but that would
mean they'd need to split the armies
want to fight from its walls and the
adder that cannot fit inside Winterfell
to fight outside its walls it says that
John is the northerners didn't sell it
in the little force of the Nights Watch
their outside of Winterfell they'll sell
it form a phalanx formation their famous
battle tactic a large group of them
fighting in lockstep failing says his
experience Shields but this formation
they once defeat in an army that was
approximately seven times bigger in
numbers while the unsullied are forming
their failings formation it says the
junction with the northerners sent a man
of the Nights Watch take a defensive
position behind the line so Chioda
freeze the journalist sticking out of
the spikes this part seems to be
confirmed by the leaked photos that
followed first stuff I had made that I
have no idea why would they make sure
with the freeze which is a defensive and
the cavalry measure consisting of a
portable frame covered with many spikes
which in this case have journalist on it
whites can only remember how to use a
sword but they cannot use bows and
arrows or other complex tools including
riding horses however this part still
seems to be confirmed by this leaked
photo in which you can see some kind of
stakes or chi woody freeze on the ground
and similar things hanging from the
walls anyways back to the outline beside
John snow are his direwolf ghost aria
dolor said Lord glory Lord manually Lord
serving ginjury torment hound perk
Brienne Podrick and Jorah jang jorim
Brienne will double in still swords berg
fills the flaming sword Taran and I'll
stay behind with the archers and walls
the army of the dead attacks battle from
Winterfell begins after seven seasons
the net king's army finally reaches
Winterfell the winter has come the
heroes are standing together against the
only enemy that matters it says that
beside John and Brienne Jarrell
Seville's the Valyrian steel sword did
Sam give Jorah his own Valyrian steel
sword heart's pain most likely s such a
powerful weapon isn't useful in the
hands of a maester while it'd be pretty
useful in the hands of Sam's friend your
moment Davos on your hand will seemingly
once again lead the archers just like he
did in the battle
the bastards but this time he's
accompanied with Tyrion the outline
continues with the northerners suffer a
lot of casualties the unsullied stay
strong they're heavily outnumbered
Tyrion doesn't move his eyes from Jon
Snow that was nervously looks across the
battlefield as he orders the archers to
begin volley firing Tyrion holds a horn
grave or most nervously looks at Jon
Snow as he starts losing some of his men
most of the Nights Watch perish thurman
finally nods to John from across the
battlefield signaling him that they
lured all the army of the Dead to attack
the middle of their formation allowing
them to encircle their army at that
moment Jon turns around and nods to
tyrion tyrion blows a horn the track in
Knights of the Vale appear out of
nowhere
Koen only to the chakki Lord Royce leave
the Knights of the Vale in their charge
towards the back of the army of the Dead
the army of the Dead is outflanked and
outnumbered the battle and shortly John
Stone knows that war is not won yet
since there was no night king or any of
the White Walkers in his battle he knows
there must be more of the army of the
Dead but the first battle has been won
John looks at Tyrion and smile stearin
smiles back but not for too long
Tyrion sees rest of the army of the dead
front of Winterfell walls
Tyrion realizes that they defeated only
the small number of whites the remaining
whites accompany with the undead Giants
led by the White Walkers sir marching
towards them basically John's strategy
did work but only a small amount White's
the rest of the night Kings armies yet
attack it says John immediately commands
everyone to retreat inside Winterfell
some don't manage to get inside before
the army of the dead reaches them some
can't enter the gates because it's
already too crowded Tyrion has to order
the gates to be closed and barred most
of the northerners the Knights of the
Vale and the unsullied are inside
Winterfell
most of the directly remain outside
Taryn orders them to use their cavalry
as an advantage against the army of the
Dead that doesn't have any to the track
er overrun some managed to flee monster
killed and immediately reanimated by the
White Walkers
I got a stop right there to say that
this part has also been governed by many
leaked photos and leaked videos it says
that most of the track here overrunning
slaughtered by the night king's army nor
shortly after brought back to lie by the
White Walkers to basically act as their
minions here you can see the Trekkie
whites riding on horseback as already
said we've never seen a white riding a
horse which might change once the
Trekkie become part of the knight king's
army these are definitely to the track
whites
one would think that this might be the
White Walkers we have already been seen
riding horses but during the filming the
White Walkers are just guys in
prosthetics and may
except for their blue eyes which are
added in post-production the green suits
like the ones we consumed is the Trekkie
however used for whites the decayed
skeletal kind is achieved with the help
of visual effects hence the green suits
the clothing and saddles of these
veidt's also feed to the track style
this episode is the bloodiest episode
ever in Game of Thrones besting the
winds of winter and the Battle of the
bastards full of war full of danger ok
guys this will be the first half of the
episode while the other half is
currently in the process and will be
released as soon as possible make sure
to stay tuned for the second part
because it is even better than the first
half every moment of this episode is
intense many main characters will be
dying and unfortunately even some fans
favorites are dying and no one is safe
it contains the rest of the battle
between the living and the dead with
Jaime Lannister's appearance with more
characters dying with the arrival of
urine and the golden company at
Winterfell but Jon Snow being captured
and me tiara Greyjoy being rescued
additionally just like in the first half
most events in the other half are also
confirmed by the leaked photos and leaks
and as always I hope you guys enjoyed
this video if you did please make sure
to subscribe to our Channel and I hope
to see in the next one peace
[Music]
[Music]